I'm not gonna lie to you I'm on my phone
probably eight to ten hours a day what
are you doing mindlessly scrolling and I
try to convince myself that if I keep
scrolling something will inspire me do
you track screen time on that you know
in the settings yeah I want to see daily
average is 7 hours and six minutes
messages 13 hours Instagram 10 hours
Snapchat 8 hours tick tock four hours
messages
I mean maybe talking to
business people
in social media fitness space from what
I've heard and everything maybe men get
respected a little bit more it's harder
to break through and get paid good
looking girls especially in the fitness
space can monetize guys and girls good
looking guys really only monetize guys
you're right in the monetization aspect
but also in the brand partnership aspect
I think guys are treated a little bit
better I've heard my friends like due to
their engagement or whatever she should
be getting paid more and then I know a
guy is below her on engagement following
everything and he's getting paid more
than she is and I'm like well she's
getting finesse